it's my great plan
welcome you to this event and confirm
also on behalf of real University and
its president Peter Salovey we have been
talking about organizing a conference
like this and illicit traffic and
looting since the last six months pretty
early on when I joined Yale University
last April Martin and we got in touch
and thought that would be really a
primary aim of the time to bring experts
and professionals together to discuss
this issue a little could we know that
on April 14 we would be doing this in an
entirely different context and we
thought about it to half a year ago I
think for the Yale University which has
been a university since 1701 in New
England New Haven Connecticut the first
century maybe being a university for the
American East Coast and in the second
century maybe a university for the whole
country but now it has clearly global
ambitions and wants to be a global
University and of course a university
like yeah with global ambitions has to
lend its voice has to become an Agora
for discussions like this discussions
which are clearly in need of a global
and international response it's not so
much about our voice but it's really
about your voice and I would like to
thank all the speakers and all the
participants who followed our invitation
as Martin was saying to come here to
London to the Victoria and Albert Museum
I mean you are the essential voice in
this debate and to the same extent also
those colleagues who actually as Martin
said send video presentations
powerpoints but who could not be here in
person because they are facing
completely different conditions of work
in their daily life in Syria in Mali
Nigeria Yemen Libya and Iraq we have
together with my colleague Vernon Rutley
we have structured the conference in
different sessions from lessons learned
from the past current concerns on the
ground a very important session about
working together perspectives actually
in all its diversity as Vernon loves to
call it to embrace the diversity of this
debate I think is very important as well
and of course ending with a roundtable
discussion chaired by Hammond Pat singer
from the Prussian foundation of cultural
heritage about international
perspectives and the role of museums I
think that cultural heritage is about
identity it's about knowledge it's about
the future as well as it is about the
past I think by coming here you make a
strong point to emphasize that at stake
at the moment is much more than just
artifacts in archaeological sites I'm
looking forward to a interesting day of
a lot of shared knowledge martin has
said what we can maybe expect as an
outcome in the evening let's see how far
we get but I'm very happy that you came
and thank you